hallo mein name ist luca und ich zeige
euch heute drei besteuerte simulator
games bieten so wie es aussieht ist das
hier der asphalt simulator
das ist übel spray sie meine maus geht
aus dem bild heraus wie schlecht ist das
denn
falls euch darunter nichts vorstellen
könnt ihr die maus geht einfach raus ich
sehe mich um und die maus geht einfach
aus wie dumm das hier ist der emotions
violetta und wir müssen wie rede ich
denn jetzt mit denen wenn meine maus die
ganze zeit hier draußen ist wir können
ein bisschen rumlaufen ein paar leuten
reden wurden als da wären wir eine frau
die sich ja richtig süßes haus day
positiv space bar
was ist das für ein scheiß die neue
hammer wenn ihr euch denke dass ich
vielleicht in den boden hüpfen kann oder
irgendwas anderes machen kann aussagen
dank der zwei verschiedene augenpaare
auf so ich will einfach nur eine pizarro
dummkopf auch kummer hier vorne level
und hier kommen wir leider nicht rum
ach das ist ein spiel wie spiele drin
sind hat das komplette spiel hier
besteht daraus dass sich diese scheiße
hoch kicken muss das ist toll dass du
dich jetzt viel besser fühlst repression
ich glaube viel mehr kann ich hier nicht
machen da steht eine auf dem dach könnt
ihr mir hier vielleicht sagen was da
gerade passiert sagen wir ein stück gold
talking to people
wie kann ich denn mit ihr reden ich kann
ja nicht mal treppen oder so hochgehen
ich komme hier nicht durch ich komme
hier nicht das ist wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten simulator in diesem spiel
müssen wir ein auto steuern ich bin in
diesem fall das untere auto und muss
wow ich habe gerade herausgefunden dass
sich mitglieder das andere auto steuer
das sieht nach sehr viel spaß aus ich
kann jetzt mit dem oberen auto
und es ist alles wieder von vorne ich
war zwar mit beiden gleich schnell und
versuche dass sie sich in der luft
treffen
es ist einfach das dümmste spiel aller
zeiten ist unsere auto kann ich gar
nicht mehr zocken da bewege ich die
ganze zeit irgendwas passiert einfach
nichts und beim oberen auto kann nicht
wenigstens irgendein coolen spruch hier
noch machen irgendwie dann hier und
jetzt hier
es muss doch irgendwas cooles passieren
oder hinten trick champion
mein gott bremsspuren waren wir gerade
und wenn ich ins wasser fahre ist
einfach wieder alles von vorne
beim dritten simulator müssen wir
hamburg auf jeden fall es ist der
dessauer und wir müssen
die können jetzt hier auch menus
election klicken auf facebook sondern
können wir ihr oma neverdie altach koma
jetzt können wir ja auch noch hier
das ist sehr freizügig in die wir ja das
ist ja hammergeil dieses spiel ich kann
ja komplett anziehen wie ich will kann
ich der theoretisch nicht auch noch den
bio meine sachen wie kann die komplett
nackt machen
wenn ich hier rein theoretisch stehen
ja ich werde mal eben kurz wieder was
anziehen damit ihr da nicht hier soll
kommen jetzt hat sich den rettern damit
das macht gar keinen sinn hier geht's
hosen zur auswahl und ich kann nur ihren
oberkörper sehen was ein scheiß alter
ich habe sie gerade komplett nackt
gemacht läuft auch schon mal her
ich habe gerade einfach mal kommen
vielleicht zurück ist ja dann sagen wir
jetzt mal das ganze jetzt fertig ist wie
zeige ich denn dass ich fertig bin ich
bin jetzt werde ich mit ihr ich habe
jetzt einfach mal so angezogen wie ich
im sommer eigentlich auch vom laufen
werde und zwar so also mit so einem
tollen ich habe so einen badeanzug
angezogen dann ein viel touristik
headset und wundervolle touren die
schuhe
was mache ich hier ich will das video
hier beenden wenn solche gefallen hat
dann steckt eine banane und 18 mann im
kreis und schreibt dass ich ein toller
hund